3 en 1 3 candidats aux élections
européennes en un rendez-vous
d'auditions publiques bonsoir à tous en
ce premier jour donc de la campagne
officielle trois invités ce soir acteurs
et témoins de la gauche fracturée
yannick jadot tête de liste europe
écologie les verts bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous pour 20 minutes ensuite ce
sera au rang laluque de la liste ps
place publique et enfin ian brossât tête
de liste du parti communiste français
yves très rare est avec moi avec orianne
mancini sera tout autant d'ailleurs
stéphanie le rouge et brigitte boucher
me rejoindront donc pour ce rendez vous
des chaînes parlementaires de la fp et
du figaro et les internautes du figaro
d'ailleurs peuvent bien sûr réagir comme
chaque semaine sur le chat du journal je
me ferais l'interprète de vos
interpellations de vos interrogations de
vos questions pour nos trois invités
donc le relief jadot yannick jadot je le
constate
europe ecologie les verts stagnent
yannick jadot je croyais un gel constat
les sondages publiés par le journal de
notre ami y va
vous stagné donc alors est ce que c'est
vraiment la preuve que désormais toutes
les autres listes ont réussi à vous
déposséder du sujet de l'environnement
non pas du tout je pense que on entre en
campagne il ya encore beaucoup de
confusion sur cette élection c'est que
tout va se jouer la dernière semaine et
puis vous savez moi je suis un amoureux
du football regarde beaucoup la ligue
des champions la finale de la coupe de
france
et vous voyez que ce sont les dernières
minutes qui comptent je suis bien sûr
vous verrez qu'on ferait un très bon
score parce qu'alors comme vous l'avez
dit comme vous l'avez dit le jour en
vironnement gde vous stagne et non
l'environnement est au coeur de cette
campagne et je crois que une fois la
campagne terminée
les françaises et des français
reconnaîtront que le seul vote utile
efficace pour protéger l'environnement
et pour sauver l'europe c'est celui
d'europe c'est combien
à l'arrivée à vous verriez le score
allait un chiffre à manon sera on aura
un score à deux chiffres
moi je dis qu'on sera au-dessus de 12%
alors daniel cohn bendit que vous aimez
bien d'ailleurs ce matin sur une radio
disait mais il serait peut-être pas la
bonne campagne c'est une campagne
beaucoup trop agressive que paye annick
janot et c'est pour ça qu'il a des
sondages qui sont des sondages qui sont
pas tout à fait à la hauteur de ce que
vous prétendez avait savoir être vous
savez il ya dix ans quand on faisait la
campagne avec dany cohn bendit une
semaine avant on était sur le même socle
c'est 8 % c'est la dernière semaine où
tout s'est fait écouter des nids cohn
bendit je pense qu' aujourd'hui c'est
compliqué pour lui de soutenir une tête
de liste qui passe et qui paraît une
secte mais je sais bien mais bon il veut
masquer finalement le le le il est allé
plus loin que ce que dit wie die
aujourd'hui les verts français sont une
secte est ce que vous vous sentez l'âme
d'un yannick jadot
oui c'est un départ d'un copain se
battre et c'est pas très sérieux pour sa
part de sa part de dire ça mais je pense
que c'est pas facile pour lui de dire en
deux ans qu'est ce qu'il a obtenu de la
part des manuels mâcon qu'est-ce qu'il a
obtenus sur l'écologie rien emmanuel
macron comme françois hollande et
nicolas sarkozy avant malheureusement ce
sont des reculs des renonce
toute action
mais t es ce que vous avez été
aujourd'hui que l'écologie est le
patrimoine de tous les partis politiques
et que tout le monde à part ah mais moi
je suis très heureux que tout le monde
en parle c'est aussi notre victoire est
aussi votre mais non mais non c'est
notre victoire culturelle que l'écologie
soit au coeur du débat sur l'europe mais
après avec la culture elle va pas
entraîner une défaite dans les urnes
mais du coup parce que jeune raisons de
voter pour mais non mais tout le monde
parle d'écologie oui mais s'ils
voulaient le problème qu'on a avec
l'écologie c'est pas d'en parler c'est
pas faire des discours c'est pas de
faire des promesses ça depuis que chirac
la maison brûle tout le monde en a fait
l'emballement climatique s'accélère
l'anéantissement de la biodiversité on a
eu un rapport
regardez sur notre territoire on
continue artificialisés les sols nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ne
baisse pas la pollution de l'air
soixante sept mille morts prématurées
par an noz et de son odeur et grey's
anatomy
oui mon élan mais dans l'orne et trois
années n'ont maintenant rien corrigé
mais on a eu trois émissions régresse
grâce notamment à l'action de l'union
européenne quand on est dans une session
initiation climatiques un peu
particulier aujourd'hui l'europe est le
bon élève de la planète que je veux dire
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'à un moment
donné
l'écologie c'est agir est le seul groupe
politique qui obtient des avancées au
parlement européen sur l'environnement
la santé des libertés c'est le groupe
des verts alors si vous voulez moi je
veux bien avoir une une candidate tête
de liste en marche qui nous met le pot
de piment d'espelette aoc
tout ça c'est très bien fait je défends
je défends les terres sauf que de
l'autre main elle signe tous les accords
de libre échange qui tu y es t rois qui
tuent notre agriculture revenir au pays
en regardant puisque ce sont des
élections européennes ce qui se passe
dans l'union européenne on voit qu'en
allemagne
les européens les verts allemands sont
en deuxième position dans les sondages
ils sont une force centrale de la vie
politique allemande est scellée en
france c'est elle je vais peut-être
parce que vous avez du mal justement
vous et vous n'avez pas ajuster votre
disque sommet il ya un discours et
agressif comme dit david habite alors
que j'en arrive et il arrive à s'adapter
non moi je suis pas agressif tout ma
campagne c'est sur le terrain avec les
apiculteurs avec les entreprises des
énergies renouvelables avec les artisans
pour l'isolation des logements je suis
en permanence sur l'écologie comment
expliquer mon cas ils ont dans ce
journal à vous répond il ya un an
il ya un an il était à la moitié tant
mieux ils sont hélas ça renforce la
nécessité absolue qu'il y ait un vote
écolo fort en france de ski maginez
l'allemagne la belgique les pays bas la
france avec un vote écolo puissant ce
serait pas simplement un groupe fort au
parlement européen ça serait le signal
que l'écologie doit être au coeur du
paysage politique européen et que même
les gouvernements auxquels nous ne
participons pas doivent cesser leur
inaction sur l'écologie et commencer à
agir juste et les écologistes sont forts
en allemagne en belgique aux pays-bas
comme vous dites et que vous vous faites
le score qu'on vous prédis est ce que
les verts français ne serons pas
affaiblis au sein de votre groupe
européen n'ont pas ce qu'on fera pas le
score qu'on nous prédit aujourd'hui
parce que la campagne c'est le résultat
de la ligne d'arrivée c'est le 26 mai et
je le répète
franchement regardez l'europe il ya cinq
ans personne n'imaginait le break cite
personne imaginer salvini personne
n'imaginait la montée des extrêmes roth
depuis cinq ans la crise écologique
selon tous les rapports scientifiques
s'est accentuée s'est aggravée et
pourtant on a les solutions et moi ce
que je veux pour notre pays et pour
l'europe c'est pas simplement qu'on
parle d'écologie c'est qu'on agisse et
qu'on aurait tous les emplois liés à la
transition a désigné cette innovation
ces entreprises qui participeront de
cette transition
l'actualité s'accélère d'ailleurs sur
les kings soucier de l'environnement
oriane on peut interroger notre invité
notamment sur le glyphosate rien avec un
rapport et une prix
deux positions politiques qui font débat
alors quelques prises de position celle
du sénateur pierre médevielle qui a dit
ce week-end dans une interview le
glyphosate et - cancérogènes que la
charcuterie ou la viande rouge qui ne
sont pas interdites qu'est ce que vous
dites je dis que je regrette qu'au
moment où il y à des révélations sur
comment monsanto essayent d'influencer
les responsables politiques et les élus
des élus justement reprennent mot pour
mot les éléments de langage fournis par
monsanto à tous ceux qui veulent qu'ils
quittent ils ont réussi à mettre sous
leur sous leur influence pour protéger
les glyphes ozap vous savez c'est quand
même terrible on a aux états unis en
france des procès où la justice condamne
monsanto pour des personnes atteintes de
maladies et de cancer on a le centre
international de recherche sur le cancer
caddie cancérogène probable
on a tellement de paysans qui sont
sortis du round up qui vivent mieux la
santé l'environnement la qualité
notamment la biodiversité la rente et la
biodiversité et la rentabilité de leur
exploitation paul françois vous avez
tous relaté paul françois le céréalier
de charente qui a gagné après douze
années contre monsanto et ben c'est 240
hectares de céréales
il les a convertis en bio et ça se passe
extrêmement vous avez lu ce rapport
parlementaire et en sortir ben non ça
n'est pas lui mais non on est on est on
est lille et dès que les déclarations de
médias elle alors ce rapport
parlementaire ne dit absolument que dix
sénateurs tout à fait en attendant il ya
douze pages consacrées au glyphosate et
dans ses douze pages ce rapport dit il y
met un pied d'égalité toutes les
recherches qui ont été faites en disant
on sait pas le bilan fait que la plupart
des des recherches européennes notamment
disent que ça na fin un lien mais les
séquences et de scientifique monsieur
très sympa de conscientiser tous les
journalistes et les journalistes
français ont particulièrement bien
travaillé sur ce qu'on a appelé les
monsanto peppers taire toute cette
communication interne à monsanto qui a
été révélé ce qu'on sait c'est qu'à
chaque fois qu'il ya une étude qui est
sorti
pour dire il ya un risque c'est
dangereux monsanto a soutenu financer
organiser une science biaisée pour
pouvoir contrarier l'action des
responsables politiques eh bien je dis
là aussi sur le glyphosate
le numéro quatre de la liste en marche
monsieur 2 crd qui est reconnue dans les
dernières révélations comme un soutien
précieux au glyphosate et à monsanto et
ben nous quand on est sur les listes de
monsanto
c'est comme des opposants donc ceux qui
veulent sortir du glyphosate ceux qui
veulent offrir un avenir à nos paysans à
notre environnement à notre biodiversité
à notre climat et à notre alimentation
c'est nous l'ailé parlementaire où le
candidat effectivement que vous citez
l'agriculteur numéro quatre de la liste
dans la liste vous estimez que ceux qui
sont fichés comme soutiens se sont
là-bas et ses obsessions s'est révélée
dans toute la presse
ils sont indiqués comme fervent soutien
sur les documents importants pour le
glyphosate et pour mon secteur intérêts
ah mais vous savez le problème c'est que
les coopératives non les coopératives
agricoles dans ce pays vivent comment
non mais vous savez comment les
coopératives agricoles qui sont
essentiellement dirigée par la fnsea y
vivent de la vente des produits des
pesticides à l'état dit on va pas sortir
en vàd leader oui mais alors ça vous
gêne pas que à chaque rendez vous
médiatique où il est interrogé depuis
10,3 en fait attention mais non je vais
pas un procès d'intention je vois
comment les choses sont organisées vous
rendez compte moi j'ai fait le grenelle
de l'environnement
avec nicolas sarkozy on avait dit on
réduit de moitié les pesticides
de 2008 à 2010 8e on est à plus d'un
pour cent
on n'a pas réduit de moitié on a
augmenté de 20% et on a dépensé l'argent
public
700 millions d'euros dans des plans ce
dos volontaire de sortie des pesticides
on a augmenté et franchement il est
temps pour l'avenir notre culture nous
on propose de sortir au niveau européen
des pesticides en quinze ans que large
de la politique agricole commune 9
milliards d'euros d'argent public par an
en france ça serve à aider tous les
agriculteurs d'accord à la fois à avoir
un revenu décent mais avoir un revenu
décent en protégeant notre biodiversité
en protégeant notre alimentation en
protégeant la santé accords et des
paysans et de nous en restions sur mer
sont tantôt puisque vous avez parlé de
ce fichage des politiques et des
journalistes vous avez annoncé votre
intention de porter plainte au nom
d'europe écologie les verts vous l'avez
fait je suis servi lundi ça a été bon
poser le disais ok les sujets pendants
sont multiples sur les questions
environnementales on apprend ce soir à
la lecture du monde que renault en fait
est mise en cause désormais pour son
système de dépollution un qui était
apparemment à bord de ces véhicules
inopérant à basse vitesse c'est-à-dire
en circulation urbaine est ce que là ça
vous donne en tout 52 rendez compte que
il ya eu des réunions comme nous autour
d'une table où des dirigeants
d'entreprises ont décidé que ils
bloquaient les systèmes de dépollution à
moins de 50 km c'est à dire que quand
les diesels circulent en ville ils
polluent trois fois quatre fois au
dessus de la norme autorisée
c'est là où nos enfants tous c'est là où
on peut plus courir c'est là où nos
personnes âgées sont en difficulté je
considère que ce sont des actes
criminels
ce sont des morts prématurées à l'appel
est donc en allemagne des patrons
d'entreprises ont été le patron d'audi
avec quatre mois en prison
les autorités allemandes et pourtant le
lobby automobile est très puissant en
allemagne les autorités allemandes ont
exigé des constructeurs qu'ils
reprennent les voitures qu'il est bon
qu'il ait récemment dès aujourd'hui leur
nouveau dirigeant de renault
mais je demande à ce que renault assume
comme psa parce que vous allez voir psa
c'est exactement la même chose on a huit
millions de véhicules diesel dans notre
pays qu'ils dépassent au moins de trois
fois la norme autorisée
je demande que l'on fasse comme en
allemagne on exige des constructeurs
automobiles qui récupère les voitures
qu'ils les réparent à leurs frais pour
les rendre aux consommateurs
c'est pas possible qu'on vous y y la
santé la vie de nos enfants parce que en
trichant en fraudant de manière
justice landais à l'état d'agir contre
eux nous faut et puis l'état enfin vous
souvenez vous le gouvernement landes
comme celui là qui va l'europe pour
flinguer les normes que nous avions
élaboré nous au parlement rappeur nous
écologistes étaient date limite auprès
des constructeurs pour qu'ils arrêtent
le diesel à moi il faut en sortir en
disant il faut arrêter de produire du
diesel en disant débordés
c'est à dire garder d'ici à 2029 on doit
sortir du lit
il faut arrêter les systèmes ailleurs si
vous allez voir que finalement avec tous
ces scandales
ça va aller beaucoup plus d'accord et
combien d'autres doivent disparaître du
coup mais n'ont jamais ces questions
chez moi parce que je mets ta question
avec ces questions je que j'entends ça
alors hein en quoi une autre
motorisation empêche de produire des
voitures
deuxième chose vous savez moi j'avais
suivi un cas extrêmement patient mais
l'ivresse d'être pertes d'emplois dans
l'industrie
oui mais on va faire autre chose ah on
fait des trous vous savez que les dans
les transports collectifs ont créé plus
d'emplois dans les transports collectifs
de transport individuel donc nous
voulons un plan d'investissement sur le
transport collectif mais attention
moi j'ai suivi bosch vénissieux bosch
vénissieux faisait des des systèmes pour
le diesel
bush allait fermer ils ont avec la base
des salariés
il avait proposé à bord un plan de
reconversion industrielle
il était parti sur le photovoltaïque ça
marchait très bien jusqu'à ce que
malheureusement comme d'habitude ce pays
décident d'abîmer de mettre des bâtons
dans les roues aux autres industries du
futur qui est l'industrie des énergies
renouvelables dont il ya plein de
perspectives de reconversion secte sur
d'autres secteurs des biens meilleurs
pour notre son gros événement économique
est impacté par cette mobilisation
nécessaire bien sûr pour l'environnement
de serre pour la survie de l'humanité
c'est le secteur qui se joue à rien on
est d'accord là dessus c'est donc aussi
le secteur du 26 mai là c'est le bord du
siège mais vous parlez le vote du siècle
de du kérosène puisqu'il ya un rapport
qui n'est ni à la commission européenne
qui préconise une taxation du kérosène
pour les vols intérieurs à l'union
européenne
c'est une satisfaction pour vous c'est
bien évidemment vous voulez quoi
dissuader les français de prendre
l'avion puisque c'est ça l'objectif
c'est vous savez quand vous allez faire
le plein avec votre voiture vous êtes
accès à quoi 50 60 % quand vous prenez
l'avion vous êtes taxé à 0 aux états
unis au canada au japon dans plein de
pays
le kérosène et taxes et donc on est dans
une sorte de paradis fiscal du kérosène
en europe
à part quelques pays comme la suisse
d'ailleurs qu'il le faudrait donc il est
temps de taxer le kérosène c'est une
mesure de justice fiscale
et puis vous savez nous notre combat au
nouveau revers il faut une taxation des
prix des billets des tickets d'avion des
billets d'avion bien sûr pour que y
compris comment il n'en sait comment
vous la houle organisé cette taxe comme
ça déjà un taxer le kérosène
on peut parfaitement taxes et vous savez
les avions quotidienne des motards mais
pas au moyen-orient dire non parce que
ça ça états unis savent maintenant vous
ayez fini le fond aux etats unis le font
sur les vols intérieurs
nous ce qu'on veut c'est qu'au niveau
européen puisque nous avons la
possibilité de le faire quand le fasse
sur les vols intérieurs ce seront des
milliards qu'on pourrait investir dans
les transports collectifs savez pour les
écologistes c'est simple moins d'avions
plus de trains d'accord moins d'avions
moins que ce train à moins de personnel
dans les camps crise le jour-même
annonce un plan les jeunes et les tout
le monde se déplace
est ce qu'on peut imaginer un moment que
l'aviation qui est un secteur qui est en
train d'augmenter ses émissions de gaz à
effet de serre donne sa juste part à la
lune ou dérouler le tapis rouge à des
compagnies qui viennent de pays
justement ou de secteurs du monde où on
ne respecte pas justement cette ville
vous savez pas là le souci de l'écologie
quand c'est vrai qu'on est favorable à
ce qu'on appelle un protectionnisme vert
c'est à dire une taxe carbone aux
frontières de l'europe pour que il
justement pas de mise en concurrence de
nos entreprises avec des entreprises
issues de pays qui ne font pas d'efforts
pour le climat et de la même façon nous
souhaitons que les produits qui sont
issus de pays qui ne respectent pas la
liberté syndicale soit interdite du
marché européen
à un horizon de 5 ans et 1 ghz et
largement
partagez j'ai remarqué par m et par le
ballon une question ce registre est open
source que tout le monde mais les
questions sur la gestion qu'on reprenne
nos propositions dans les discours dans
les campagnes pourquoi d'accord mais
j'ai du mal à ces gens là et ne votent
pas quand ils ont été dites moi quel est
le pourcentage véritable au secteur
aérien dans les émissions de co2
aujourd'hui ces 3 % à 3 % 1 3%
mais c'est en effet une augmentation à
pour 169 par exemple assure c'est l'un
des secteurs qui le secteur comme le
secteur des transports un secteur de
l'asie numérique les des portables par
exemple ça pollue plus que ce qu'on fait
mais moi je vous savez on s'est battus
au parlement européen notamment pour qui
et on a gagné c'est encore une victoire
du parlement européen pour qu'il n'y ait
plus qu'on appelle les minerais de sang
dans vos portables c'est à dire que une
bonne partie des minerais très rare qui
conditions utiliser un portable viennent
du bassin du congo sont exploités dans
des conditions dramatiques oui c'est
vrai encadrés par des murs yann qui
violentent tout le team est pas
justement faisons de la traçabilité
aussi sur les chaînes publiques et
examine en ce moment à l'assemblée
nationale hier vous avez une phrase qui
a provoqué quelques remous on va dire
vous avez dit que vous étiez favorable
un grand débat national sur le statut de
la fonction publique pour voir comment
rapproche le statut de la fonction
publique et le statut de la fonction
privée est ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer est ce que vous êtes pour une
remise en cause du statut là
fonctionnement mais non il ya plein
d'emplois notamment dans la fonction
publique qui sont des emplois vie et
c'est normal ça protège dans l'intérêt
général
l'intelligent mais s'est pas améliorée
dans les secteurs régaliens dans l'est
dans les hôpitaux dans les trucs
il ya plein de choses moi ce que je veux
c'est qu'il ya toute une partie de
population et notamment les plus jeunes
qui n'ont accès à aucun statut
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne sont quasiment
protégés de rien et moi je vais une
harmonisation par le haut de tous les
statuts à coeur et notamment donner un
statut à ceux qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas
trouvé ça bien que le gouvernement
facilite le recours aux contractuels ans
parce que c'est celle là
du gouvernement aujourd'hui c'est la
précarisation des statuts aujourd'hui
dans un monde où tout le monde se sent
particulièrement précarisés
particulièrement vulnérables il faut
notamment donné de nouvelles c'est
effectivement pour la statue il faut
notamment donner aux salariés de
nouvelles sécurité y compris autour des
questions d'environnement à l'est est
comprise au tour des familles
répondez-moi par oui ou par non à cette
question d'un internaute nuit côté
europe écologie voter pour le climat lui
ôter pour l'europe ma question était
celle ci c'est philippe qui nous demande
pour lutter justement contre contre la
pollution contre la dégradation de la
planète faut-il limiter les naissances
oui non non non voilà bon rallye c'est
pas comme ça qu'on fait graver ses sacs
ses salons les voitures sacré s'appelle
la dictature ça s'appelle une dictature
et éduquer les petites filles va
convoyer donner des activités
économiques au maire et vous verrez que
la transition démocratique se fait
toujours pas la libération des femmes
par l'égalité femmes hommes et par les
enfants à l'école c'est comme ça qu'on
dans la limitation des naissances non à
la dictature verte nous dit ce soir
yannick jadot merci merci enfin pourquoi
pourquoi faut voter pour l'europe
pourquoi pas les jeunes à y voter pour
l'europe procure alors ni l'espagne pour
ne pas dicter par d'autres que les
jeunes se mobilisent et civils
merci yannick jadot on ne peut plus
l'arrêter ses finitions à les deuxièmes
par europe écologie vous avez fait son
entrée sur ce plateau
bonsoir et merci
voilà ils se croisent ils se saluent
laluque bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
ce soir
quatrième sur la liste conduite par
raphaël glucksmann qui d'ailleurs de
vétroz notre invité alors il s'est
décommandé au dernier moment il avait
une urgence l'ignorent nettoiement
content d'avoir géré je ne sais pas je
ne sais pas ce que c'est moi je ne
connais pas par coeur une équipe c'est
bien d'avoir des femmes aussi un petit
peu de bons annoncé confiance les uns
les autres
brigitte boucher nous a rejoint avant
soir brigitte alors donc
je le disais tout à l'heure la gauche a
du mal à exister
dans cette campagne c'est quand même
l'un des autres enjeux du scrutin on va
parler des questions bien sûr
fondamental de l'avenir de l'union de
l'environnement puisque c'est quand même
votre spécialité les questions
écologiques
mais quand même il ya des partis qui
jouent leur survie notamment celui qui
vous soutient le parti socialiste
voulait dire c'est ça non c'est pas
c'est pas que c'est pas les partis qui
jouent leur survie
c'est la gauche qui joue qui joue sa
survie et nous comme anne hidalgo l'a
dit on est en train d'essayer d'ouvrir
une porte pour pouvoir reconstruire avec
les bonnes volontés sur des balles sur
des bases claires et saine
donc c'est pas c'est pas l'avenir des
partis c'est pas ça le problème je crois
que le parti socialiste mais assez en
danger même pour pouvoir essayer de
justement contribuer renouvelle à gauche
il n'était pas obligé de donner latence
de l'hystérie obligé de donner la moitié
des listes de l'armée ne pas avoir de
député européen à strasbourg
moi aussi pour n'est pas adepte
convaincu alors montréal c'est parce
qu'ils sont à romont tada c'est qu'on
voit ce qui se passe sur le terrain et
sur le terrain les salles sont pleines
on rajoute des chaises on voit des gens
qui n'étaient pas là avant on voit des
gens doutent ou le figaro sous les 5%
sous le seuil de député européen la
lettre commence
elle a été assez étouffé à la fois dans
le grand débat et la campagne
descendants regarder un badge entre des
nationalistes et des soi-disant
progressis commence la campagne nous
franchement sur le terrain ça se passe
très très bien que la dose normale quand
on regarde ailleurs en europe la social
démocratie se porte plutôt bien elle
arrive même au pouvoir en espagne se
porte bien au danemark en finlande
est-ce que c'est pas un problème
français finalement même de la gauche la
gauche quand elle fait ce sur quoi elle
s'est engagée
effectivement elle va bien elle est
réélue et là il ya un besoin de 2
de montrer qu'il ya des alternatives de
renouveler un candidat d'être réformiste
et radicale besoin de renouer avec ce
que vous avez à dire dans cette campagne
européenne
qu'est ce qu'on a à dire on a à dire
qu'on représente l'alternative pour une
autre il n'y a pas de contenu je finis
ma phrase
il y aura peut-être du contenu ou gérer
après nous sommes la gauche qui revient
justement la gauche écologique la gauche
féministe la gauche qui veut porter la
démocratie lutter contre les lobbys nous
sommes ceux qui allons alliés justement
la question sociale et la question
environnementale aux avis yannick jadot
tout à l'heure le plateau il nous fait
des sorties assez étonnante qu'il tente
de contrecarrer après sur la question
des fonctionnaires j'ai bien entendu il
s'est expliqué je pense qu'il est en
train de rétropédaler sur la question la
taxe sur les transactions financières
par exemple on voit bien que plein de
partie non c'est est censé aider les
pays du sud
c'est pas grand chose c'est une petite
taxe et on voit très bien que la
république en marche mais europe
écologie et verts aussi à mon grand
étonnement décide de la donne et non pas
à la solidarité internationale
mais à la transition écologique tout ça
fait qu'on s'est vraiment des autres
la taxe carbone tout le monde la reprend
maintenant un erasmus pour tous tout le
monde également un smic européen on
l'entend aussi à la république en marche
qu'est-ce qui vous identifient
finalement ils nous disent antifi c'est
justement ce lien entre social et
écologie et que notre programme liszt au
sérieux mais justement je viens viens de
montrer justement que europe écologie
est bien en train de faire un recul sur
ce sujet nous proposons un pacte climat
biodiversité qui est un plan
d'investissements au niveau européen qui
est le plus ambitieux que vous avez pas
celui de la rm n'est pas ambitieux qui
les 2000 milliards sur cinq ans le nom
des 2 400 milliards par an il n'est pas
financé les autres et finances et celui
d'europe ce à travers une réorientation
des subventions à travers une
réorientation de la politique de la
banque centrale européenne à travers
aussi un impôt européen qui est
l'impensé finalement de la république en
marche qui dit pourtant extrêmement pro
européenne et bien quand on aime
l'europe ont la finance
les 3% de déficit public alors justement
sur cette question là nous ce qu'on
propose c'est de sortir les dépenses
environnementales les 3%
premier point deuxième point pour
réorienter les politiques publiques
européennes
on propose d'ajouter d'autres critères
soient déjà été fait on sait y ait ou
pas qui elles tupac le six pack donc ces
critères ont évolué nous ce qu'on dit
c'est qu'il faudrait ajouter des
critères environnementaux et des
critères sociaux toujours lié les deux
toujours les la question sociale
à la question environnementale je vous
cite aurore l'a lu que vous avez des
liens instant nous sommes la gauche qui
revient et j'ai compris on vous écoute
tant que ça n'était pas la gauche qui
avait régné avec françois hollande
vous êtes d'accord je me trompe j'ai
toujours été assez critique d'accord
donc cela dit je n'ai pas dit ça en
inventaire olivier doligé on peut être
critique sans dire que ce n'est pas la
gauche mais l'inventaire d'olive effort
était assez claire quand même sur le
sujet ne semble et il me revient c'est à
dire à peu en rupture avec la politique
qui a été menée sous françois hollande
je ne suis pas démenti quand je dis ça
et pourtant je vois aujourd'hui votre
tête de l'épreuve non raphaël lui
jouanno milieu des revenants justement
du hall en dise madame hidalgo
alors vous n'avez pas john
vallaud-belkacem voilà qui sont là pour
essayer de leur gonflé non c'est pas
pour le rendez vous n'avez pas vu que ce
matin par exemple on a reçu toute une
jeune génération d'élus je pense à la
maire de rennes et clermont ferrand etc
etc on était bonne quinzaine et que rafa
luxe man a reçu ses élus on a trahi
trahi une longtemps
j'étais avec lui à ce moment là donc je
savais où les mécènes taubira et au
contraire ça m'a plombé iata incomber la
liste noire parce que je dit du tout je
suis en train de dire qu'il ya toute une
nouvelle génération qui est fait ce lien
entre écologie et social qui est en
train de le porter et qui soutient kial
qui a le soutien de grandes figures
comme madame taubira et bien d'autres ya
cinquante élus qui ont dit qu'ils
soutenaient la liste envie d'europe
donc c'est un rassemblement qui commence
plutôt bien ma vie parce que vous avez
pas peur qu'il n'y ait pas de député on
l'a dit au parlement européen alors que
et bien justement la social démocratie
arrive à se maintenir dans les autres
pays bas en france en france est ce que
vous êtes victime finalement d'un
discours qui a oublié de se renouveler
et d'un discours qui est assez peu
original par rapport aux concurrents que
vous avez devant vous et à côté de vous
pour cette élection européenne
le discours que nous avons maintenant
non je crois qu'hier le social et
l'écologie je suis désolé de vous le
dire mais ça fait 30 ans qu'on l'entende
annonce a fait pas 30 ans qu'on entend
social-écologie moi j'ai vous dire j'ai
travaillé j'ai fondé un think tank sur
les questions de transition sociale
écologique il ya dix ans on opposer
systématiquement 10 ans la question
sociale et la question environnementale
était impossible de lire et de ça a été
tout notre travail à nous au angie de
montrer que la question environnementale
et est toujours une question sociale que
ce n'était pas une bille de bobos que
c'était les plus pauvres dans tous les
pays du monde qui pâtissait le plus du
dérèglement climatique et de la perte de
biodiversité que c'était les plus riches
au sein de chaque pays et à travers le
monde qui polluent et le plus est que
jusqu'à présent les fiscalité
environnementale toucher les plus
pauvres et pas les vues
pour vous occuper des minorités tout à
l'heure vous visiez eh bien on va vers
des minorités qui n'ont pas droit à la
parole et vous n'avez pas un peu
brouillé le peuple dans ce cadre-là pas
pas du tout à ce jeu c'est le pas pour
moi c'est tout mon tête histoire de
déconnexion entre les élites et du
peuple
j'ai un petit peu un petit peu du mal le
peuple sait c'est nous tous nouveaux
contrats
ce qu'on propose c'est un plan
transition écologique sociale qui va
permettre de créer des emplois
on propose un bouclier emploi pour
pouvoir aider aux transitions par
exemple je prends la question de la
fonderie du poitou
ils sont sous traitants dans les
questions dans les questions automobiles
dans tout ce qui touche à l'âme
automobile une partie des fonds des mâts
s'occupe de tout ce qui est diesel
essence une autre et sur l'hybride et
bien aujourd'hui celle qui est dans le
domaine du diesel et de l'essence est en
souffrance et pour aider à la faire
cette transition
il faut protéger les salariés pour
qu'ils puissent se former
c'est l'idée du kursaal bas et en
allemagne c'est le bouclier emplois que
nous défendons c'est à dire continuer à
rémunérer à hauteur de 98% les personnes
pour qu'elles puissent se former plutôt
que maître lee mettre au chômage
technique qui est un traumatisme pour
l'entreprise et c'est un traumatisme
pour le salarié voilà on a plein de
solutions concrètes qui mêle justement
le pouvoir d'achat l'emploi et la
question environnementale je prolonge un
peu la question de vivre sur le peuple
et les minorités puisque vous avez
critiqué la position d' emmanuel macron
sur les frontières il a dit récemment le
chef de l'état personne ne peut venir en
europe sans y être invité et vous vous
êtes indignés vous considérez que c'est
un discours de la droite la plus dure
c'est ce que vous avez dit quelle est
votre position sur les frontières est ce
que vous êtes pour des frontières
ouvertes mais il ya des règles de droit
qui doivent être respectées après on
peut passer on peut pas laisser les gens
se noyer dans la méditerranée et a eu
dix sept mille personnes qui se sont
noyées dans la méditerranée ces
dernières années c'est pas admissible
pour impayés pour un continent qui
défend des valeurs aussi importantes que
les nôtres de laisser des gens
revoir les accords de schengen non
lesecteur de schengen
il faut voulait rester comme ça s'allume
en garde plein pour voir dublin
évidemment il nous faut des voies
légales
en fait ce ne sont pas les ong qui font
que je dépasse heures contrairement à ce
qui a été dit et ce qui était très
choquant c'est le fait qu'il n'y ait pas
de quoi légal il nous faut dévoiler les
noms de l'intérieur
il nous faut des visas humanitaires de
toute façon quand un pays est en guerre
quand un pays traverse des famines on
n'empêche pas les gens de fuir et c'est
tout à fait logique
moi je suis maman vous êtes peut-être
parents vous aussi excusez moi mais
quand derrière vous il ya des fusils et
ben vous l'a traversé la mer qu'on vous
dise que vous allez être arrêté ou pas
aux frontières ce qui va vous des quotas
d'immigration pour accueillir ces
immigrés dans différents pays
et si jamais il y en a qui refusait ce
qu'il faut le leur enlever des
subventions européennes pour qu'ils
acceptent cette répartition juste je
crois parce qu'ils sont des quotas je
crois par contre qu'il va falloir créer
un vrai dialogue rang français le statut
d'asile au niveau européen est une terre
preuve de solidarité
mais riche des murs autour et des
frontières la france enfin l'allemagne a
été d'une générosité incroyable a fait
ce qu'il fallait faire l'italie aussi
aujourd'hui ce qui est en train de se
passer en espagne
françois asensi socialiste auquel vous
êtes associé aujourd'hui je suis ni de
rassemblements encore une fois aidé
n'est pas d'accord sur tout je pense
qu'un inventaire qui a été fait et nous
on estime que ce qu'on fait quand il y
avait des gens qui se noient dans la
méditerranée c'est qu'on les sauve c'est
une autre de voix que la politique d'
aide de francs structurelles doit être
corrigé en fonction de la politique qui
est conduite sur le plan national
j'entends dans les pays d'europe
centrale par exemple
actuellement il ya une grande polémique
et grande polémique au niveau de
l'europe en disant il ya des pays qui
tordent un peu
diraient les droits de l'homme notamment
en pologne notamment en hongrie est ce
que eux il faut revoir la politique
d'attribution des fonds structurels
quand ils seraient ils agissent ainsi
mais quand ils n'acceptent pas la
solidarité notamment pour l'accueil de
l'article a été en partie déclenché je
sais pas si c'est ce qu'il faut faire
je pense que on a un gros souci au
niveau européen de projets il nous faut
un projet qui nous réunissent tous
ensemble plutôt qu'un projet qui nous
sépare et c'est ce qui est en train de
se passer au niveau européen et la
montée des populismes c'est tout ça
finalement ce sont des peuples qui se
sentent méprisés et qui finalement vont
s'en prendre aux autres par effet de
ricochet mais qui sont peut-être plutôt
en colère après nous parce qu'on les a
laissés tomber on n'a pas aidé le pays
les peco les pays de l'est sont les a
pas aidés comme on a aidé en son temps
j'avais très bien que françois curiel
sont allés d'abord chez eux bénéficient
largement encore aujourd'hui repas fini
comme on a aidé autant l'italie le
portugal l'espagne au début la
construction européenne on les a pas
aidés autant quand on regarde quand on
regarde la réalité des chiffres
il va falloir trouver un moment un
projet qui nous réunissent tout ce qu'il
nous fasse du bien et qui nous
permettent de deux contres et justement
c'est populisme je savais moi je suis
économiste et - comme les économistes
préféraient s'appelle keynes et keynes
au sortir de la seconde guerre mondiale
avec churchill avec roosevelt qui
étaient pas des gosses idée gauchisme
semble-t-il idsud et il se dit c'est pas
la relance allait revenir au spirit et
par le déficit et par sait jamais ce
qu'a dit kent si la prospérité churchill
a dit la seconde guerre mondiale la
seconde guerre mondiale
la seconde guerre mondiale elle a eu
lieu à cause de la social démocratie
européenne avec les hyènes aujourd'hui à
cause de je crois pas juste je finis là
dessus à cause d'absence de prospérité
pour unir le peuple il faut de la
prospérité partagée était facto des
fonds dont nous dépendons une europe
providence d'accord et vous dressez donc
contre les nationalismes populisme mais
c'est également un peu la latitude ou la
posture que se donne emmanuel macron est
ce que ce n'est pas donc paradoxal de
souhaiter son affaiblissement au soir du
26 mai je trouve que emmanuel macron
aidants
de forme de populisme fondamentalement
le maquereau nice mais est devenu un
populisme et il a peut-être toujours été
c'est vrai dans le sens où son programme
déjà n'est pas sérieux quand on aime
l'europe
on propose un programme sérieux il
propose de faire tout ce qu'il n'a pas
fait au niveau européen et tout ce qu'il
n'a pas fait au niveau français au
niveau environnemental il propose des
exemples très clairement par exemple la
liste des paradis fiscaux
il veut lutter contre les paradis
fiscaux au niveau européen alors qu'en
france il a proposé une liste de moins
de dix pays qui n'est absolument pas
crédible dans lesquels on trouve des
pays qui n'ont rien à paradis fiscal
comme le botswana
par exemple il est oubliée qui siégeait
au conseil européen monsieur emmanuel
macron la banque climat biodiversité que
nous défendons il en a jamais parlé
c'est dans son sexe et oui pourquoi
emmanuel macron il sait aussi un
référendum pour au cours lui maintenant
vous l'avez bien vu en live une baisse
que non mais jugé qu est ce que vous
pensez qu'il doit quitter le
gouvernement comme le dit le front
national ses qualités soldes qui sait si
les choses s'étaient pas les questions
non parce que ce n'est pas un référendum
c'est une élection c'est une élection
européenne quand est ce qu'on parle
d'europe quand est-ce qu'on arrête de
parler de la france et je reviens sur la
question de la banque de la banque qui
m'a dieu dire c'est que nous défendons
il avait deux ans pour la proposer il
n'a rien fait concernant les directives
il dit qui s'opposent aux extrêmes par
exemple mais il s'est allié avec la
hongrie dorman pour torpiller la
directive sur les recenseurs dallaire
pour lui la torpille est la directive
sur le congé parental et plus ça fait
but oui je pense
mais certaines formes si vous êtes élu
chez les sociaux démocrates nous l'avons
dit parce que le vrai clivage au tous au
niveau européen
c'est entre la gauche et d'eurodéputé
sociaux démocrates
on va voir mais pour l'instant les
sondages donnent 50 cent quarante à peu
près tout petit peu plus
non ça augmenté ces derniers temps mais
c'est ça qu'on doit faire que les excite
une élection euros
donc ya pas de clivage entre soi disant
progressistes et les nationalistes le
vrai clivage au niveau européen et pas
au niveau français au niveau européen ce
entre la droite et la permanence vous le
savez bien c'est je suis alors on les
rampes avec ça c'est justement pour ça
qu'il va falloir être fort au sein du
groupe social-démocrate pour pouvoir
peser pour pouvoir proposer une autre
version
premier des compromis toute façon je
vais vous dire au parlement européen il
n'y a pas forcément groupe majoritaire
d'autres joutes ont à chaque fois
trouver des dalles et enfin toujours des
alliances tous les groupes font des
alliances quel qu'il soit donc on n'est
pas pour la grande coalition mais on
veut peser pour pouvoir réorienter
justement les politiques lancent des
états à bruxelles
est ce que vous êtes pour la remise en
question de la règle de l'unanimité qui
prévaut dans beaucoup de domaines sans
la question de la fiscalité c'est très
problématique effectivement mais juncker
on a parlé il ya quelques mois il a fait
une sortie semble-t-il dans le financial
times pour dire que va falloir
probablement revoir cette règle
néanmoins on néanmoins on oublie qu'ils
à la coopération renforcée qui existent
au niveau européen et qu'on peut avancer
avec un petit groupe de pays il a dit
qu'il était pour l'adhésion d'autres
états à l'union européenne de 2 qui
veut-il parler ce qui l'est pour
l'adhésion de la turquie à l'union
européenne
je ne sais pas je
une vie pas ou quoi bon d'accord alors
merci beaucoup
vous souhaitez aussi bonne chance à
benoît hamon vous avez été très proche
de lui vous avez un compte en donner
j'ai écouté si ça comme une trahison moi
je trahis pas mes idées mes idéaux et je
ne trahis pas ma volonté de dépenser du
4 mai je voulais le rassemblement et
qu'il me semblait j'avais des gages qui
était d'honneur du conseil de révision
est alors à gauche à les détruire il n'a
pas fallu le rassemblement symbolique
merci beaucoup or la lutte et vous salue
ray bien sûr effet le luxe même de notre
part merci beaucoup à vous c'est ian
brossât qui fait maintenant son entrée
sur le plateau pour la troisième partie
d'auditions publiques
ian brossât bonsoir tête de liste du
parti communiste français dans ces
élections européennes avec stéphanie le
rouge de la fp qui nous rejoint alors
vous allez être la surprise de cette
élection gellusseau ce matin dans
l'humanité si vous le dites mais
l'humanité est un très bon journal que
vous avez raison de dire tous les matins
exactement surprise car vous fait
sensation c'est vrai tout le monde et
j'ai lu aussi dans le figaro et que vous
étiez la bonne surprise aussi elle vous
donner un coup de jeune au parti
communiste français
ian brossât pas écouté pour lui être
content de ce que je suis heureux de ce
que vous n'êtes pas dans les sondages
explique effectivement médiatiquement on
va dire en pensez mais bien accueilli
que populaire populairement dans les
sondages en tous les cas des intentions
de vote
ben c'est pas encore tout à fait ça mais
parce que c'est une campagne c'est une
campagne qui en réalité démarre pour
beaucoup de français beaucoup de
français ne sont pas aujourd'hui dans la
campagne ils ont plein d'autres choses à
faire que de s'intéresser à ces
élections européennes donc il nous reste
deux semaines et je suis convaincu que
nous réaliserons un bon résultat et que
ces élections marqueront le retour du
parti communiste sur la scène politique
dans sa vie la crise plutôt social en
france depuis maintenant quelque cinq
mois à polluer ces élections européennes
en mal je ne dirais pas ça je pense au
contraire que cette crise sociale ces
mobilisations celle des gilet jaune mais
les mobilisations de manière plus large
ont permis de pointer du doigt les
injustices sociales qui existent dans
notre société
sixième puissance économique du monde 9
millions de pauvres dont 3 millions
d'enfants
ce sont des questions qui doivent être
au coeur de la campagne des élections
européennes et puis par ailleurs ce qui
s'est dit à travers ces mouvements ce
sont des choses que le parti communiste
porte depuis très longtemps
l'augmentation du smic l'augmentation
des salaires le nécessaire partage des
richesses
tout cela ça renvoie des revendications
que nous portons beaucoup
d'abstentionnistes celle et gilet jaune
qu'on vous espérer contrer ça parce que
voilà ils sont plutôt dans un dégagisme
général vis-à-vis de tous les
représentants
ce que je veux dire à ceux qui nous
écoutent et il ya peut-être des gilet
jaune parmi eux beaucoup d'électeurs de
gauche aussi qu' aujourd'hui envisage de
s'abstenir
j'ai envie de leur dire vous savez ce
qu'ils vont bien ceux qui se portent
bien les banquiers ce qu'ils ont plein
d'argent ils vont toujours voté et donc
je veux leur dire que si vous qui
peut-être avait des difficultés qui
souffrait du chômage qui souffrait des
bas salaires si vous ne votez pas vous
n'aurez pas demain de représentants pour
vous défendre au parlement européen donc
pour que ce soit équitable
il faut que tout le monde aille voter et
il faut notamment que ceux qui sont les
plus en difficulté à y voter comme on se
rend en manifestation vous avez des
députés ce qui peut encore évident des
députés européens puisqu'il faut 5 % une
barrière qui n'est pas encore tout à
fait atteinte de votre part où siégeront
les députés communistes européens
là où il siège dans le camp de
strasbourg là où il siège depuis
toujours
les communistes ont déjà un gros pot
parlement européen c'est le groupe de la
gauche unitaire européenne qui compte 52
membres alors c'est un groupe qui est
minoritaire puisqu'il ya en tout 750 et
un eurodéputé cela dit c'est un groupe
et ce sont des députés qui ont fait la
preuve de leur efficacité je prendrai un
exemple concret l'aide alimentaire
le programme européen d' aide
alimentaire il était prévu qu'ils soient
supprimés
il profite à 3 millions de français qui
sont les plus en difficulté ce sont les
députés européens communiste qui l'ont
sauvé je crois que c'est un bel exemple
qui montre l'utilité d'avoir des députés
communistes au parle est ce que vous
êtes comme marine le pen vous souhaitez
un échec de la liste macro nice tu
ferais quoi qu'il arrive en deuxième
position derrière le rassemblement
national pour affaiblir le chef de
l'état car marine le pen qui a un
discours social où vous l'avez noté elle
dira si le manuel macro arrive en tête
et il va pouvoir faire passer la réforme
de l'assurance-chômage d'assurance des
retraites est ce que vous tenez ce
discours là à vous aussi
il y à hofu une gigantesque arnaque
on essaye de nous faire croire que cette
élection européenne est le remake de
l'élection présidentielle et le
président de la république emmanuel
macron fait tout d'abord transformé une
le pen qui voyait les deux ça n'est pas
un dû
c'est un duo et ils ont l'un et l'autre
intérêt à transformer cette élection
européenne en un remake de l'élection
présidentielle faire un dogme anti ou
pro massa n'est pas le sujet c'est un
référendum sur les politiques libérales
qui sont appliquées à l'échelle de la
france et à l'échelle de l'europe et le
parti communiste a ceci de cohérent et
de constant qu'il a rejeté tous ces
traités européens ultra libéraux y
compris l'acte unique sur lequel le
rassemblement national à l'époque
s'appelait le front national s'était
abstenu c'est à dire qu'il a laissé
passer l'acte unique et les 300
directives de libéralisation qui sont
passés derrière le parti communiste lui
il est constant il est cohérent sur
cette question là non pas parce que nous
sommes en attendant la dénonciation tous
les accords intérimaires dans la
dénonciation de ces traités européens
vouloir un sujet au parlement européen
et à être qu'on voulait être quelque
part souverainiste je ne suis pas
souverainiste en tout cas je suis très
attaché à ce que nous sortions de ces
politiques libérales
la question ce n'est pas d'être non et
l'heureux que nous avons et le rôle que
nous avons toujours eues nous nous
sommes battus par exemple pour faire en
sorte que les travailleurs de la route
ça fait l'objet d'une directive récente
ne souffre plus du dumping social et que
à travail égal salaire égal et qu'on ait
plus cette espèce de concurrence sauvage
qui fait que des routiers roumains sont
payés 500 euros quand ils travaillent en
france donc on a la grâce aussi à
l'harmonisation sociale par le haut
entre internautes h et on arrête ce
système absurde qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
on met en concurrence le travailleur
français avec le travailleurs polonais
et on met en concurrence le travailleurs
polonais avec des travailleurs du meneur
français qui sont eux mêmes détachés
parce que celui des hommes
le csn qui ont été corrigés en confiance
soyons sérieux alors siens le cadre mais
oui mais lorsqu'un cadre français va
travailler en roumanie
vous croyez qu'on la tire vers la
roumanie avec un salaire de 500 euros
donc de fait le problème ne se pose pas
puisque les travailleurs détachés
français qui vont travailler dans les
pays de l'est
ce ne sont pas des ouvriers se sont
plutôt des cadres donc le problème ne se
pose absolument pas de la manière c'est
absurde vous emmener surtout surpris
monsieur grosseur oui je ne veux pas en
rester à l'idée que madame le pen un
discours social parce que ça n'est pas
la réalité en tout cas elle tient
peut-être un discours social
mais la réalité de ces actes et y con
prix des actes des députés du
rassemblement national au parlement
européen ça n'est pas le social du 10
mai par ailleurs aujourd'hui je suis
prêt demain à des majorités de projets
avec par exemple la france insoumise
elle loge berry dire une chose est ce
que vous avez vu ce qu'ont décidé ses
alliés autrichien il dirige l'autriche
en ce moment il ya un gouvernement
d'extrême droite en autriche
ils ont mis en place la semaine de 60
heures 60 heures de travail par semaine
et madame le pen veut nous faire croire
que c'est avec ces gens là qu'elle va
construire l'europe sociale il n'y a pas
une arnaque quelque part puis par
ailleurs madame le pen elle n'est pas
favorable à l'augmentation du smic elle
n'est pas favorable au retour de l'impôt
de solidarité sur la fortune est sans
doute parce qu'elle est concernée elle
même
étanche athlètes et pas vous non plus
qu'elle arrive en tête donc le 26 mai
dont a indiqué à ce sujet c'est un
scrutin à la proportionnelle pas quelle
heure et c'est un scrutin à la
proportionnelle
on élit nos eurodéputés on n'est pas là
pour dire ça n'a aucune importance dans
le classement
non ça n'est pas du sujet un pacte
politique majeur surgériens le sujet
c'est de savoir combien on aura deux
députés européens pour refuser ces
politiques libérales gauche en france va
cette élection européenne plus émietté
que jamais vous êtes conseiller de paris
vous fait alliance avec madame hidalgo
qui est socialiste
vous vous entendez plutôt bien avec un
dès le premier tour pourquoi vous
n'arrivez pas à faire une union de la
gauche
au moins avec le parti socialiste avec
monsieur hamon pourquoi vous n'y arrivez
pas à faire ça parce que ce n'est pas le
même sujet etc autant dans une ville
comme paris on peut se mettre d'accord
sur le logement sur la voirie sur les
transports autant sur la question
européenne
il y a toujours eu un débat qui a
traversé la gauche je vous le disais
tout à l'heure le parti communiste a
refusé tous ces traités européens ultra
libéraux le parti socialiste et ça n'est
pas lui faire insulte à voter tous ces
traités européens
ils ont voté l'acte unique ils ont voté
le traité de maastricht
ils ont voté le traité constitutionnel
européen et même quand nous étions au
gouvernement ensemble la question
européenne était une question sur
laquelle nous n'étions pas d'accord donc
il faut admettre que sur un certain
nombre de sujets on n'est pas d'accord
et ça n'aurait pas été honnête
et jean terrain ville avec on répondre à
la question du frère ça n'aurait pas été
honnête de se retrouver sur une même
liste
si nous ne pensons pas la même chose sur
la question européenne est par ailleurs
le parti socialiste a dirigé le
parlement européen avec la droite
pendant des années donc de fait nous ne
sommes pas d'accord sur cette question
là ça ne nous empêche pas localement de
construire des majorités sur des enjeux
locaux les fans et je précise et juste
qu'il ya eu des discussions encore
tardive avec benoît hamon lui dit même
qu'il était prêt à se ranger derrière
votre numéro 2 madame bon l'art pourquoi
ça ne s'est pas fait puisque
actuellement vous vous êtes autour de 3%
lui autour de 3% également et vous allez
certainement l'un comme l'autre ne pas
avoir d' élus
d'abord je ne vous permet pas de dire
que nous n'aurons pas d'élu je me bats
tous les jours pour en avoir et je suis
convaincu que nous en aurons parce que
c'est un objectif qui est tout à fait
atteignable ses huit cent mille voix et
je suis convaincu que nous les aurons
pour le reste moi j'avais souhaité que
nous puissions faire alliance avec
benoît hamon nous y avions d'ailleurs
fait un certain nombre de propositions
en ce sens
ça n'a pas été possible je ne veux pas
refaire l'histoire simplement je
voudrais m'adresser à ceux qui nous
écoute et leur dire que au fond dans
cette période très confuse à gauche je
crois qu'il faut faire confiance
justement à des gens constant et des
gens cohérents et quand on élit député
européen communiste on sait dans quel
groupe ils vont siéger au parlement
européen
on sait ce qu ils voteront on sait
qu'ils refuseront les privatisations les
fameuses directives de libéralisation
on sait qu'ils défendront les petits et
l'intérêt du plus grand nombre
donc je pense que justement dans cette
période très confuse le parti communiste
peut être un repère et vous alors vous
dénoncez l'europe libérale depuis le
début de cet entretien
ian brossât vous dénoncez aussi j'ai
remarqué l'europe austérité gens
viennent vous demander où est ce que
vous avez vu ça en france nous avons une
dette qui s'approche de 100% de notre
richesse
le déficit se creuse et puis emmanuel
macron a renoncé quand même tout à fait
récemment à essayer de resserrer les
cordons de la bourse nos pays très
endettés tout cela pour satisfaire les
gilets jaunes alors où est ce que vous
avez vu que l'europe était osterrieth
air au point d'imposer sa politique et
sa vision à la france
d'abord je le vois dans les traités
européens dans les traités non mais non
rien est fait par tout nbc partout
michel grossiord où je me balade en
france je vois des fermetures de
services publics et je vois des français
de gauche comme de droite pensent public
vous permettez qu'on par le chef de
l'état retire non ce sont 2 mai et
postes de fonctionnaires
c'est à vous permettez qu'on vous
répondre allez-y et qu'on interrompe
peuvent vos questions par mes réponses
ce que je vois partout en france ce sont
des mobilisations pour défendre les
services publics qui fernand 20 ans nous
avons perdu 40 % nos maternités au cours
des 20 dernières années le nombre de
femmes et maternité on peut ouvrir le
chantier de maternité mais bien sûr rien
que les femmes elles votent aussi avec
leurs pieds elle parfois elles
choisissent d'aller accoucher dans des
cliniques sécurisées avec vous n'aura
vrai plateau technique vous le savez
trouvez vous normal que l'an dernier
dans le lot il y a eu quinze femmes qui
est à coucher sur la route
est ce que vous croyez que c'est bien
est ce que vous trouvez que c'est normal
est ce que vous trouvez que c'est digne
de la sixième puissance économique du
monde non je ne considère pas que ce
soit normal de même que je considère
absurde qu'on continue à fermer des
petites lignes de chemin de fer jugés
non rentables et du coup on oblige les
gens à utiliser leur voiture et à
polluer donc je vous le dis l'austérité
je la vois partout et je la vois dans la
mobilisation de tas de gens qui refusent
la ferme zulu décision avis plusieurs
publications comme ça sur l'europe pour
au contre la révision des accords de
schengen
non je ne suis pas favorable à la
révision des traités de dublin non enfin
pardon les accords de dublin où il vient
durable ce sont des accords qui sont par
ailleurs absurde et qui sont pour
beaucoup dans les campements qui se
multiplient un peu partout
est ce que l'europe doit aller plus loin
et plus vite sur l'interdiction du
glyphosate
oui elle va bien elle doit le faire le
plus rapidement possible les députés
européens il ya ce plutôt absolument
d'ailleurs lé député européen communiste
et snow
groupe de manière unanime avait demandé
l'interdiction immédiate du glyphosate
sur les aliments non pas le report à
cinq
stéphane y avait une question justement
sur les questions environnementales est
peut-être là c'est peut-être là que se
niche la révolution du parti communiste
français
tout le monde se réclame de l'écologie
dans cette dans cette campagne en tout
cas de la république en marche à la
france en soumis c'est une priorité
vous avez plutôt l'image d'un parti
productiviste comment vous intégrer
cette problématique dans votre programme
d'abord nous sommes profondément
attachés à l'écologie à la défense de
l'environnement je considère pour ma
part et j'espère ne pas être le seul
qu'on ne peut pas d'un côté dire on
défend l'environnement et de l'autre
continuer à défendre un système ultra
libérale qui consiste précisément à
n'avoir que la recherche du profit pour
objectif dans le nucléaire
même si on est prêt aujourd'hui le parti
communiste a toujours été le parti
communiste dit deux choses la première
chose que nous disons c'est qu'il faut
réduire la part du nucléaire dans notre
mix énergétique et la deuxième chose
c'est que la meilleure énergie est celle
qu'on ne consomme pas et que donc par
exemple l'un des objectifs que l'union
européenne devrait se fixer
c'est un plan massif visant une
meilleure isolation de nos bâtiments
c'est quand même la question centrale
c'est 40 %
c'est 40 % de nos dépenses énergétiques
tout le monde le dit mais faisons le
utilisons par exemple l'argent de la
banque centrale européenne qui a versé
3000 milliards d'euros aux banques
privées depuis dix ans qu'un peu de cet
argent puisse aller vers un plan pour la
rénovation énergétique de nos bâtiments
c'est ce que j'ai fait à paris en tant
qu adjoint en charge du logement nous
avons rénové quarante mille logements
sociaux on ya mis un milliard 5 55 % de
gain énergétique si on était capable de
faire ça à l'échelle européenne on
rendrait un grand service à
l'environnement petite correction sur la
banque centrale européenne si la banque
centrale européenne a injecté n'injecter
pas autant d'argent dans nos pays ou
bien vous auriez des taux d'intérêt très
élevés et ses taux d'intérêts très
élevés pénaliserait les plus modestes
je n'ai pas dit qu'il fallait pas le
faire simplement à elle verse 3 mais
elle a versé depuis
dix ans trois mille milliards d'euros
aux banques privées sans aucune espèce
de conditions ni aucune espèce de
contrepartie et j'ai dit que si une
petite partie de cette somme était allé
vers la transition énergétique ça aurait
été pas mal quand même
alors vous mener différents combats ian
brossât notamment j'ai vu contre les
gaffes à et leur puissance comment est
ce que vous avez vécu l'entretien
accordé par emmanuel macron à monsieur
zuckerberg le patron de facebook a été
reçu avec comme un chef d'état comme un
chef d'état
1 est ce que c'était ça nous a choqués
vous avez dit oui c'est la bonne méthode
pour essayer de réduire l'influencé les
excès du réseau social et même les
dangers que facebook peut faire courir
on le voit sur la démocratie
eh bien je vais vous le dire j'ai fait
l'expérience alors à paris il y a
quelques années le patron fondateur de
facebook
airbnb avait été reçu en grande pompe
par la mairie de paris et nous lui
avions fait gentiment un certain nombre
de demandes a rien obtenu a rien obtenu
du tout et donc le constat que nous
avons fait c'est que le seul moyen d'y
arriver face à ses gaffes à c'est le
rapport de force et y compris un certain
nombre de procédures judiciaires
moi ce que je constate c'est qu'on a
aujourd'hui des gaffes a qui sont plus
puissants que les états les gars fassent
et 3600 milliards d'euros de
valorisation boursière plus puissants
que les états ils dictent leur loi et il
se fiche totalement de nos législations
locales et nationales donc croire qu'on
y arrivera simplement en leur demandant
gentiment de bien vouloir respecter la
loi
je n'y crois pas pas on n'a pas fait que
des souris on n'a pas simplement
revendiquer ameublement je crois que le
gouvernement a arrêté une taxation
récemment dégâts face à ça va dans le
bon sens vous avez vu vous avez vu cette
taxe 500 millions d'euros au début
cinq cents mais reste un tout début
début ce n'est pas une taxe c'est une
taxe confettis leader leader vous rendez
compte le gouvernement présente cette
taxe comme une grande victoire
elle va rapporter peut-être l'année
prochaine 500 millions d'euros soit 7
fois moins que l'impôt de solidarité sur
la fortune dont on nous avait dit qu'il
fallait le supprimer parce qu'il ne
rapportait rien donc j'ai quand même un
peu de mal à comprendre l'argumentation
du gouvernement
la réalité c'est qu'il nous faut nous
battre à l'échelle européenne
vous savez pour une également son
contour une harmonisation fiscale
il n'est pas normal il n'est pas normal
que ces multinationales soient taxés à
9% vous savez qu'on a des intérêts alors
même nos pme payent leurs impôts des
efforts les allemands ont dit non
précisément parce que justement il
voulait pas se mettre mal avec les
américains notamment sur le marché
automobile de se pendre à un ton nous on
ne peut pas accepter que ces
multinationales fassent leur loi et que
dalle mais que dans le même temps nos
petites pme payent leurs impôts a mis
sur lons et commencez vous utilisez
facebook vous utiliser ils veulent à
présent sur facebook vous pourriez ne
pas collaborer avec ces géants de l'art
garit d'état d'éditorialistes du figaro
qui dénonce le fonctionnement de la
sécurité sociale utilise la sécurité
sociale donc si vous voulez qu'on joue à
ce petit jeu là ce sera contradiction
pour contradictions frappe à côté on va
pas organiser le combat simplement parce
qu'on manque de temps
l'émission s'arrête là merci beaucoup
merci tous les deux bonsoir à tous et la
semaine prochaine votre score alors on
la remonte à da pour vous c'est combien
allait du dépasseront les 5% 800 mille
voix c'est accessible et nous aurons des
députés européens ça redonne 4
merci bonsoir à tout ça très vite
[Musique]